aaron rodgers was watching the draft
very intently on uh the first night as
he was as he explains
to kyle brandt in a podcast that
officially debuts
next month but a piece of it was
published yesterday aaron rodgers
talking about how he was watching the
draft thinking that the packers were
going to take a receiver and also when
they traded up thinking that they were
making the move to get a receiver
whether it was justin jefferson he
mentioned him brandon ayook is a guy
that he thought the packers liked and
when they
took a quarterback instead he said he
went and he poured four fingers of
sipping tequila and braced for the
onslaught because he knew his phone was
going to blow up from all the people who
were making sure he was okay well he's
okay for now
uh he may not be in green bay a whole
lot longer though he said just look at
the facts when asked about moving on in
a couple of years and you know chris
there was a thought that this would be
his last year but it gets to something
we were talking about as it relates to
russell wilson earlier in the week when
we were speculating on his future in
seattle
it's going to be harder now to move on
from aaron rodgers in 2021 even if he
wants to move on because the salary cap
is going to be lower that salary cap hit
from trading him is going to be yeah
it's going to hurt a piece of the pie
that is gone forever but uh look i think
two years is now the the magic window
for aaron rodgers with the green bay
packers and and i think the moment they
traded up to get jordan love and
squandered their chance to build on a
team that got within a game of the super
bowl last year which i'm sure has made
him upset deep down i mean he said
nothing in that clip i saw yesterday
yeah he played it cool cause it can well
but no let me say he said nothing that
conflicted with the things that brett
favre said after he spoke to aaron
rodgers right i i believe he's upset i
believe that he sees this as we had a
chance to get back to the super bowl we
had a chance to try to win a super bowl
and you've decided to take a step back
uh i i i just think that he's gonna end
up playing for somebody else and it's
gonna be fascinating to see who it is
and when it happens yeah i hear you i'm
i'm tuned in too there's no doubt uh
yeah i i think the magic number is two
years you know and first off you know
again we we hit on this on the top of
the show but
you know the draft looks worse now
because devon functions has opted out so
now here we are back to the same group
of guys there's nothing to talk about in
green bay and the offense it's it's
aaron rodgers and devonte adams it's
it's hand the ball off to aaron jones
and and hopefully that's where that's
all there is to it you know and that's
just not fair you know other great
quarterbacks got more than that look at
brady look at mahomes desean watson all
of them you know see you know seattle
russell wilson bet all of them all the
top five quarterbacks all have better
talent than aaron rodgers not even close
you know and you can go down the list
and it's even worse than that so yeah
it's frustrating and i think you know
you the point you made about the salary
cap with aaron rodgers and all that the
dead money you're right that's going to
be hard to swallow next year with where
the number looks like it might be at
added to the fact that you know
this is like
hands down
one of the most raw this is the most raw
quarterback in the first round
and this is one of the more raw
quarterbacks we've seen be drafted in
the first round over the last few years
this is a kid in jordan love who
his good is great but there is a lot of
middle ground there and a lot of ups and
downs too when you really dive into his
film and study him and he came from a
you know elementary offense as well to
where yeah i don't even think it'd be
realistic to think he could take over
the reigns for a 2021 season i don't
think he'll be anywhere near that i
think he is the guy that truly needed
the otas needed a full training camp of
like real reps and things like that and
his reps are going to be hurt this year
because of all these circumstances so i
think realistically it is two years and
you're gonna have aaron rodgers you know
on fire i hope he drank 1942 tequila i
hope he's drinking the good stuff
well i have a feeling he can afford it
oh you think he can
yeah
yeah you know somebody somebody bought
me a bottle of that and see the problem
is i don't know who it was that bought
me a bottle of that but somebody bought
me a bottle of it once you develop a
taste for it what happens is you know
the first bottle is free
and then you realize how much it costs
and the second bottle and the third
bottle and the fourth bottle and the
fifth bottle aren't free so i would like
to say thank you very much in a
sarcastic way to the person who bought
me the no yeah 1940. hey no problem i
give up good i give out good gifts but
you know i mean that's why that's why
you know i didn't want to give you the
big bottle remember i gave you know some
of the the really important people here
at nbc i gave them the big bottle and i
gave you the smaller one i couldn't
waste that kind of money on you
you got to get your story straight
because you've gone from i said i
intentionally bought you the small
bottle too i i was supposed to get you
the bigger bottle so you're all over
that i have all the i don't know what
the hell i stand about this and clear it
up once and for all
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports